تخفي هذه الغابة الاستوائية المورقة في شمال غرب
تايلاند نوعًا نادرًا من الأنواع المهددة بالانقراض
، وهي واحدة من آخر معاقل
النمر الهندي الصيني الذي تم
صيده على حافة الانقراض
بسبب فرائه المستخدم في الطب التقليدي ،
وقد اختفى هذا النوع الأيقوني
من الكثير من مناطقه.  النطاق
في كل مكان تقريبًا في الواقع باستثناء
محمية هوي للحياة البرية هنا ، وهي جزء من
مجمع غابات تايلاند الغربية مع ما يقرب من 7000
ميل مربع من الغابة المحمية ، وهي
تشكل أكبر كتلة غابات سليمة في
البر الرئيسي جنوب شرق آسيا ، وهي
أرض خصبة
للنمور وبونجامون جامبوروم على ذيلهم.
هو مسار النمر ، لذلك أقوم
بالقياس للتأكد من أن هذا هو
مسار نمر حقيقي ، وأود أن أقول إن هذا
نمر بالغ يتمتع بصحة جيدة ،
وطريقة أخرى لتتبعهم يتبعون
أنفك ،
هذا هو رذاذ النمر ، لذا سيرش
النمر بشكل أساسي لوضع علامة على ذلك
مناطق لإخبار النمور الأخرى أن هذه
منازلهم
يعمل جون باروم لصالح جمعية الحفاظ على الحياة البرية ،
وهي منظمة غير ربحية تشاركها  قام
القسم التايلاندي بالمنتزهات الوطنية
للحياة البرية والحفاظ على النباتات في
مشروع تدريب حراس المنتزهات لتقليل
معدات الصيد الجائر منذ عام 2005.
وقد طوروا معًا نظام الدوريات الذكية ،
وهو مزيج من الأحذية على
مصائد الكاميرا الأرضية وجمع البيانات
لرصد علامات الحياة البرية
والإمكانيات  التهديدات
المسلحة والمدربة على الدفاع عن النفس ،
حراس المنتزهات هؤلاء مستعدون لمواجهات
مع الصيادين ، وعلى عكس المناطق المحمية الأخرى
في تايلاند ، لم تكن هناك
حوادث صيد غير مشروع هنا منذ عام 2013
وفقًا لجمعية الحفاظ على الحياة البرية
باستخدام 250 مصيدة كاميرا عبر
الغابة التي عثروا عليها  تضاعفت أعداد النمور
هنا على
مدار الخمسة عشر عامًا الماضية لتصل إلى أكثر من 60. بالأمس أصبحت
حفرة الري هذه في أعماق
الغابة منتجعًا صحيًا نهاريًا للنمور في
مكان ما للراحة
والاسترخاء
والالتقاء
حتى تفسح المجال في النهاية لبعض
سكان الغابة الآخرين  مثل
الدب الأسود
الآسيوي
، يعتبر الفيل الآسيوي والنمر الخنزير البري
هو قمة الحيوانات المفترسة  في السلسلة الغذائية
في النظام البيئي ، لذا إذا
نجحنا في الحفاظ على النمر ، فهذا
يعني أنه يمكننا حماية
العديد من الأنواع المهددة بالانقراض
، وكما يقول جامباروم ، فإن القطط
الكبيرة تحتاج إلى طعام
كبير ، فإن الثدييات الكبيرة مثل gower bantang و
sembardier كلها موجودة في القائمة هنا
لنمر بالغ واحد  تحتاج إلى 50 ديسمبر على الأقل
في السنة لإطعامها ،
2022 هو العام القمري للنمر الذي
يمثل الموعد النهائي الذي حددته في عام 2010 من قبل 13
دولة لمضاعفة أعداد النمور البرية
حتى الآن تشير الأدلة إلى أن أعداد النمور العالمية
آخذة في الازدياد ولكن مداها
قد ارتفع  استمر في
الانخفاض بالطريقة الأخرى التي يأمل فيها جون باروم
نمور تايلاند ،
على سبيل المثال هوي كايكينج في الوقت الحالي ،
نحن أكبر
موطن لنمور الهند الصينية ،
لذا بينما تواجه النمور في جميع أنحاء العالم
مستقبلًا غير مؤكد ،
يمكن لهذه النمور الاسترخاء
على الأقل في الوقت الحالي